today i'm going to be speaking with jim
freeman uh
who is author of the book rich thanks to
racism how the ultra wealthy prophet
from racial injustice and also director
of the social movement support lab at
the university of denver uh jim it's so
great to have you on today
thanks so much for having me david so i
mean to start with let let's
get people into sort of the thesis and
idea of the book
in what ways can racism be
profitable how do people monetize racism
yeah i mean you know the reason i wrote
the book is i wanted to introduce this
idea of
strategic racism right so particularly
after last summer there's a lot
a lot more understanding of systemic
racism
um which is which is good and exciting
but the problem is
that um not many people understand what
and who
stand in the way of dismantling that um
and
there's also a problem too i think with
the term which is which is sort of vague
and impersonal
right it makes it seem like systemic
racism is this natural occurrence it's
just
sort of part of our society um so i
wanted to introduce this idea of
systemic racism
to demonstrate to people that
there are people who are profiting from
it there are people who are racism
profiteers in this country
that there is intentionality behind
these efforts
um because you know even when we do
think that there's people on the other
side of this fight
we think about the alt-right and those
kind of folks but that's not who's been
passing all these laws that are
responsible for
systemic racism they're not the ones who
are doing the heavy lifting
in defending or expanding these policies
so
you know my work as a civil rights
lawyer has been with
um the communities that are most
impacted by systemic racism black and
brown communities i've been working with
those communities for
for 20 years and so i've seen up close
what this looks like
and how devastating it is and you know
what that really means in practice is
that
these corporate wall street executives
these ultra wealthy billionaires
they make huge investments in these
think tanks and advocacy organizations
and media outlets
that have been instrumental in
preserving defending and expanding these
dynamics such as what we see in the
criminal justice system such as what we
see in education and immigration
and and like you say they are profoundly
profitable these dynamics for the ultra
wealthy
um they make money off of mass
incarceration and immigrant detention
and immigration enforcement and school
privatization
and they also you know they pay less in
taxes when we as a society choose to
dehumanize
people rather than meeting their basic
human needs um
and then you know one thing that became
very clear i think to a lot of folks
last summer is that
systemic racism particularly you know
the mass criminalization and
incarceration
system that we have um it's extremely
effective
at controlling us at dividing us and
causing us not to recognize our common
interests
but we really saw that in how police
were used to
um to really stamp down um political
protest
so all those dynamics really help um
maintain the status quo help the ultra
wealthy maintain their political and
economic power
um and those are just you know i think
some of the ways that they profit from
these dynamics
yeah so and and that i mean that gives
us a good introduction to
a lot of different industries and
corporations that are sort of
directly connected to a lot of these
issues i'd be curious about your
thoughts before we go back to that
about i don't know i don't want to use
the term more like benign or pedestrian
corporations but just things more
associated with day-to-day like for
example
starbucks and other companies that last
summer started to make a big show
of we're going to do implicit bias
training and
all of our managers and maybe even
employees
are going to go through a course and so
on and so forth i've always
felt that that was essentially a pr
decision and and number one at
its face it didn't really pass the sniff
test for me but really what got me
thinking that
was i've not really found evidence that
that type of training
for a company like starbucks just to
pick one or others
really gets at the root of some of what
is causing these issues to begin with so
i know that we're this is kind of a
slight deviation from what you
you introduced to us but what's your
thought about that as as a source of
profit or at least of positive pr
yeah i mean you know you you make an
excellent point which is
you know last summer we had what seemed
like virtually every corporation in
america coming out with a statement
denouncing systemic racism
yes um you know proclaiming that black
lives matter
um and yet here we are you know
nine months later and what have those
corporations done
to actually dismantle these systems
right to
not just like you say do um
these sort of superficial diversity
efforts
or to you know donate some small
tiny percentage of their profits to
black owned businesses i'm talking about
you know real efforts to to address
these issues that are
harming and even killing um people in
black and brown communities
they're nowhere to be found and in fact
um for the most part there's there
they continue to be on the opposite side
of these fights so
you know one thing that um that i talk a
lot about
is is you know those
we've had those types of efforts forever
you know where
we we talk about how we're making
progress right we're taking steps
forward
well we've been doing that for over a
hundred years you know what i mean
and i it's got to be clear by now that
you know those things aren't bad per se
but they're not even close to being
enough
um and you know
i think the question for us is how many
more people are we going to allow to be
harmed
how many more lives are we going to
allow to be taken while we are content
not to actually solve the problem but to
merely make
progress so i think when it comes to
racial justice we need to remove the
word progress from our vocabulary
you know i think it's time to advance
real solutions
but to do so i think it's going to
require many more people understanding
how and why
corporate america and wall street are
able to profit from other people's pain
and we're going to need many more white
people in particular to understand how
their struggles are deeply
interconnected with the struggles of
people of color
so that they recognize that the the
fight for racial justice is also their
fight
now when you talk about that
interconnection i i'm i'm leading here
in the sense that i don't think you're
talking about a sort of class
reductionism of just realizing that
in the same ways that a lot of these
racial issues relate to class
that can also be a factor for you're
talking about a different type of
interconnection am i right
i am yeah i mean i think there's there's
there's different types of
interconnection but but one was really
only
made apparent to me when i was
researching and writing the book
um which is you know as i was diving in
so the book is really an effort to sort
of follow the money behind
systemic racism what i call strategic
racism to understand
exactly where it's coming from um and
and the ideology behind it um but as i
was doing that
um it was really eye-opening for me
because
you know as i was learning more about
where this money was coming and how
strategic these investments were i also
realized how heavily invested the ultra
wealthy are in pushing a political
agenda that's been deeply harmful
to white americans as well not in the
same ways of course and not always at
the same levels
frequently not but um but what i say is
that like
if white people examine the reasons that
their lives are far more difficult than
they need to be
they will likely eventually run into the
same set of organizations and
individuals who are leading the
opposition
against racial equality yeah so you know
i for one was astonished to discover
just how enormous an influence the ultra
wealthy have on my life
and on every other white person i know
but then yes beyond that like we all
need to get to the point where we can
clearly see that
education inequities and mass
criminalization and anti-immigrant
policies and all these other racial
justice issues
don't just harm those who attend the
under-resourced schools or suffer the
effects of what we're policing or
or face the prospect of being being
deported you know if we examine our
lives carefully
we will all find evidence of harm caused
by the reverberations
from these unjust systems um and on the
flip side we also need to recognize
that you know people who are fighting
for racial justice aren't trying to
like we're often treated like we're
trying to like ruin the world
but the reality is we're trying to build
a better world that benefits all people
and that when we do address these issues
of systemic racism
it doesn't just help people of color who
have the burden
of those racial inequities lifted off
them we all stand to benefit
when our neighbors are able to live
higher quality lives
and the really rot of injustice is
purged from our systems
what are some examples of where you
think the most notable progress has been
made like in the last 10 to 15 years on
these issues
well i you know i think the most um
exciting progress
um uh happening within um
most recent memory is is around law
enforcement and the criminal justice
system
and people are really starting to
interrogate
this issue of police and the role that
they
serve and the role that they should
serve right and people are asking
questions
really important questions about how we
actually keep
our um our communities safe
and healthy and why have we tasked
so much the police departments with so
much
that really they're they're ill-equipped
to handle i mean you know that that's
certainly true
in in black and brown communities but
but it's true beyond that too i mean i
think we have to recognize
how frankly how deeply we've lied
to communities of color over the year i
mean for 40 years basically
what u.s policymakers have been saying
to black and brown communities
is is this we can we can best keep you
safe by being tough on crime
by flooding your communities with police
officers by using stop and frisk by
employing
broken windows policing and cracking
down on low level offenses by putting
police in schools
by locking up people at the highest
rates anywhere in the world
by doing the type of policing frankly
that killed george floyd and dante
wright and so many others
and all along the consistent message has
been that these were the most effective
strategies for improving public safety
but there is no evidence for that you
know there are no heavily policed and
high incarceration communities that are
flourishing
socially economically culturally they're
just none
it's a null set um so it really is
um a deep deep lie um that that we've
been telling those communities for many
years and folks are starting to see
through it
and i think that's very exciting when
you think about um some of the decisions
that are made
by corporations that are not directly
involved for example like an
incarceration as you talked about
um or some some of these other specific
areas
um it seems that there is a kind of
vicious cycle
where even you know uh a chain
restaurant
based on how it decides where to put new
restaurants
and as a result where jobs are created
and what impact that has
on the food choices of people that may
otherwise live in food deserts i mean a
lot of these things seem very complex to
me because one can find
reasons to think that almost any deci
to give a really specific example think
of a fast food
chain that says hey you know what we do
well
in poor neighborhoods that are relative
food deserts in terms of other options
there's not that many grocery stores or
healthier
health healthier alternatives and so
that's where we're
going to go and this worsens the health
of the people in the neighborhood by
making okay
the counter though is hey they're
creating some jobs in that neighborhood
though if
every such business decided we're not
going to set up shop in this
neighborhood
that's a hundred that's 200 however many
jobs that that aren't brought there
and it very quickly becomes sort of like
cloudy how should what is the what
should be the top
level interpretation of some of these
business decisions that relate to race
how do we disaggregate that and start to
pick apart something
something like that
yeah i mean i think um
i think it's certainly true that we have
to become
much more disciplined as a country
in um analyzing all of those decisions
and the policies that influence those
decisions through the lens of race
through the lens of
systemic racism and i would suggest
strategic racism too
um because and i'll go back to
to criminal justice because we were
talking about it um
you know the last summer when george
floyd was killed
when he was murdered um we were told
over and over again that it was a
wake-up call
for the nation right um but we never
actually woke up
right um if we had we would have started
to have
we would have come together around real
solutions to those issues around the
vastly oversized and violent
criminal justice system that's used
within black and white communities as a
catch-all solution for
a huge variety of behaviors we didn't
actually do that we didn't even really
start that conversation
but it's not because we don't know how
it's not because they don't have a
fix like we do um and there is
um we don't do it because there's a very
well-funded opposition that stands in
the way
right so you have organizations like
alec
representing hundreds of the largest
corporations in the u.s working for
decades to pass those various
tough on crime policies you have folks
like the koch brothers
and all these other billionaires who've
been pouring tens of
billions of dollars into various
right-wing think tanks and advocacy
organizations that have been pushing
this agenda and still do today
you have one of those think tanks the
heritage foundation
who after the uprising last summer
against systemic racism
what they decided to do was launch a
back the blue campaign a back to blue
police pledge that has now been signed
by 200 members of congress
so that's 200 members of congress who
have vowed to continue supporting the
status quo in law enforcement
right and then one of those
is that we implement these public
policies that we know
are going to inflict needless harm on
large groups of people that we know will
perpetuate racial inequities
that we know will lead to people getting
killed and then when that harm becomes
apparent
we fail to address it appropriately and
significant part because it's
economically beneficial
for the ultra wealthy so i think that's
true in criminal justice i think that's
true in education i think that's true in
in public health um and
so what we really need to do is um if
we're going to address those issues we
really need to prioritize that
and lift up those issues and
collectively start looking at these
issues through the lens of race
so that we can start to design our
public policies
in a way that moves us towards the the
just and equitable society that
that all people deserve uh the book
is rich thanks to racism how the ultra
wealthy
profit from racial injustice we've been
speaking with the book's author
jim freeman jim so great having you on
and i really appreciate your time today
thank you so much for having me david